good go it's not well I guess good
morning everyone
for the second talk of today I'm John
Dickerson I'm coming from the University
of Maryland where I am an assistant
professor of computer science I was just
here a couple weeks ago
giving a talk on some Wi-Fi issues great
some work that I've been doing in blood
donation matching markets for blood
donation and today I'll be talking about
some sort of complementary work that's
looking at the promotion of diversity
and a broad sense in matching markets
where you have some uncertainty over
potentially what vertices will arrive in
the future or the value of edges that
are going to be matched so I know that
this will be sort of old hat for
everyone here but for those who are
watching online later we'll be talking
today about matching markets and so
these are a type of problem basically
where prices aren't going to do all or
even any of the work of matching supply
and demand I'll motivate the audience
with some pictures here so here we're
going to have agents who are paired with
other agents or potentially groups of
other agents okay so will
generalizations to the be matching case
or transactions or contracts right like
so we have a lot of examples of
different matching markets traditionally
matching workers to firms children to
schools as was just discussed residents
to hospitals and sort of the very
classic case patients to donors which we
won't be talking about today for those
of you who know me I talk about that a
lot in other talks and matching
advertisements to viewers is how a lot
of us get our new fancy computer science
buildings so this is a nice problem to
think about as well and finally matching
riders to ride share drivers and so a
lot of the platform markets talks have
been from you know the uber is in the
lifts and the Dedes of the world and
they do a really interesting job of
matching drivers to riders great so
these are examples of matching problems
in today's talk I'm going to talk about
moving beyond sort of linear
maximization in these markets and this
obviously isn't the first work that does
this but I'll be focusing on it for a
particular context which is diversity
promotion great so the value of a
matching is sometimes more and sometimes
less than the sum of its individual
parts so for example let's say we're
matching workers to tasks in some online
labor market up work or something it
might be the case that we
don't want to match three identical
workers to a task instead we want to
have coverage of say somebody who speaks
English somebody who speaks French than
somebody who speaks Spanish and they're
all going to label an image with
different sort of forms of the same way
we may have soft constraints right there
might be synergies uh in the workforce
say you're hiring and you want to hire
ten programmers maybe you want five
programmers to program in Java and five
programmers who are more on the
front-end side programming in I don't
know HTML and JavaScript stuff like that
and of course we may have hard
constraints there's been a lot of nice
work coming out recently in sort of the
matching literature which looks at
diversity of via quota constraints so
another example is an internet
advertising we might want to balance the
reach and the frequency of
advertisements right the number of
individuals that we that we that we hit
with a particular advertisement roughly
is the reach and the number of times or
the frequency with which I hit a
particularly individual with an
advertisement is roughly roughly called
the frequency right so in some settings
we might have the law of diminishing
returns kick in here where if I hit your
eyeballs with the same advertisement 15
times in a row
well that 15th advertisement maybe is
going to return less value to the
central matching system then that first
advertisement or second advertisement
there's you know decades of work and the
marketing literature that looks into
that as well
so what are ways that we could talk
about diversity well we have these hard
constraints so I could have you know a
constraint in some mathematical program
that I'm solving we could have soft soft
constraints that we can push into the
objective and one way we could do that
is by using some modular functions so we
want to enforce the law of diminishing
returns well we can do this via some
modularity and again for this audience
I'm almost certain that we don't need a
slide like this but when we're watching
these things on YouTube it's good to
have them so ASA modular function f is
going to be a mapping of these subsets
of elements ground elements and of them
to the reals and we're going to call it
some modular if for every subset of
elements a and B of that set of n
elements if we add together F applied to
the union of that subset and F applied
to the intersection of that subset it's
gonna be weakly less than EPIP lied to
in each of the individual subjects there
are a bunch of different ways to write
this you can just trust me that that is
going to enforce diminishing marginal
return we're gonna call this monotone as
well if for every subset B of those
elements m and every smaller subset a of
those elements and B the value of F on
the smaller subset is weakly less than
the value of F on the larger sort of new
here this is the sort of objective we'll
be focusing on in today's talk so today
I'm gonna focus on and this is a pretty
early talk this is pretty early stage
work so I would love to you know get
some feedback from the crowd as well
especially on the last part of my talk
but we're gonna be focusing on balancing
diversity and efficiency economic
efficiency in a principled way and in
the interest of time I'll drop the the
first third of this this lecture which
focuses on offline diverse matching so I
have a couple recent papers that look at
offline in that sense I mean we know the
vertices U and the vertices V and some
body part I graph a priori instead today
I'll focus on online diverse bipartite
matching so here we're going to have one
side of the vertices in a bipartite
graph arriving online and I'll define
what I mean by that in a couple slides
so in all my diverse bipartite matching
with applications to things like crowds
or dating markets or advertising markets
we're going to be interested in say
maximizing the expected value of some
sort of function over again and I'll end
the talk with a discussion of some
ongoing work I have that looks at hiring
a diverse cohort of workers we're gonna
take a multi-armed bandit approach to
hiring so we're gonna take a multi-armed
bandit proach to learning about the
elements in our system and then we're
going to select some subset of those
elements and we'll hope that it does a
good job of doing that
right and I'll discuss this in the
context of academic hiring which is to
say graduate admission and we've been
running some experiments at the
University of Maryland which has one of
the largest computer science departments
in the nation I think of like forty
three hundred undergrads at this point
who are primary majors in CS and we have
a few hundred PhD students so we've been
running an ongoing experiment at the
University of Maryland looking at just
beginning to apply some of what I'm
gonna talk about and that's the part
that I want to get feedback on from this
crowd great and if we get to it I'll
leave you with some open questions but
these talks very rarely get to that
great so any questions so far
before I hop into this online matching
model
great so this is gonna be covering some
work with my student pound shoe who's
now an assistant professor and some
colleagues at the University of Maryland
and Karthik who's now down the street as
a research scientist at Facebook so
here's the online model that we'll be
operating in we have a bipartite graph
not shocking
we know you entirely offline and we're
going to assume that V arrives one by
one sequentially we have T time steps at
every time step T we're going to sample
some vertex B from a known distribution
D so we have some types of vertices at
every time step T well we're going to
sample a vertex be at most one it's
going to arrive and at that point we're
going to need to assign it immediately
so we can't we can't batch edges as they
arrive and irrevocably which is to say
that if I assign some vertex V to some
vertex u I can't then go back in time
and play around with the matching right
so we're going to irrevocably and
immediately assign V to and vertex U on
the offline slide or will reject me ok
so I can say I don't like UV go away I
won't get any points gonna I will make
some standard assumptions for example T
is really big and the online side is
really big compared to the offline our
goal is going to be to maximize the some
non-negative monotone it's a modular if
you recall from that previous slide some
non-negative monotone some modular
function f over the edges a that we've
matched write explicitly our goal is to
design an algorithm algas gonna find
this matching M which is a subset of the
edges e that have arrived such that an
expectation I want to maximize the value
of that F sub on to the monitor that's F
on my there will be much more online
than offline though much more online
than offline that's right
so unsurprisingly we'll take a two-phase
approach to designing this algorithm
alch will separate the algorithm into
two phases offline will obtain some
upper bound some LP upper bound it's a
math program based upper bound on the
offline optimal solution and remember we
know the distribution D from which these
vertices V are arriving we know u
entirely offline so we can do something
like this then online we're going to use
the result that pops out of our offline
optimum optimistic solution to guide our
matching algorithm
and the offline optimal solution is
going to be making heavy use of what's
called the multilinear extension of a
semaj allure function so right F is only
defined on these these these these
subsets of the ground elements so we can
create a continuous related function
capital F the multi linear extension of
that some modular function which is
defined over all subsets of the elements
N and then sort of smooth out using
these continuous variables XJ if you
haven't seen these before at a high
level the things to take home here are
that it's continuous which is great so
maybe we can do better optimization or
easier optimization with it and it's
going to be equal to the underlying
similar function f on the integral
points here and there are sort of
probabilistic interpretations of it that
say things like if we have this are our
X here which is going to be some random
sample of the ground elements such that
we've sampled an element X I with
probability X I we included in that
sample otherwise with probability 1
minus X I we don't include it in that
sample so call this our X then we can
say that the multilinear extension
capital F on that X is just going to be
the expected value of our underlying
similar function as we draw from this X
right
so that second bullet point is going to
be the intuition that we're going to use
for guiding our online solution after we
solve this offline up so our offline
phase will solve the following program
which is in our paper we show this is
this is an upper bound on what opt could
do so we're going to maximize the
multilinear extension of our underlying
monotone some modular function f subject
to some matching constraints right so
this first constraint is going to say
the expected number of matches for any
type V is going to be at most the rate
at which it's arriving right we know the
distribution offline so we have this RV
floating around as well and then on the
offline side we have a matching it
straight right we're gonna we're gonna
match every vertex U at most once in
expectation so these two constraints are
very sort of common and our objective is
going to be this multi linear extension
of that underlined semaj of the function
f so hey you know if f is linear which
is which is monotone so modular we can
solve this exactly right this is just an
LP if f is not linear if it's monotone
so modular then we can solve it
approximately yes
so we do this offline we do this offline
and it's going to give us a probability
distribution X star and we're going to
sample from that during the online phase
so what I mean by that well all right so
first solve that previous program for X
star we can do this within a nice NP
time within 1 minus 1 over you bopped
all right so if you have a lot of
computers you could you could you know
edge up on that a little bit more and
we'll design two very simple online
algorithms that will use this X star
probability distribution to do online
matching the first is going to be a
multi linear maximization based program
I'm just calling it MMP algae here
really simple idea so remember we have
you offline V is arriving one by one we
have to make a decision immediately when
V arrives we're gonna make a decision
immediately when V arrives well hey if
he's gonna arrive we have a set of edges
e that appear with V call these safe
edges right if I've matched you already
and that EU that UV edge could have
existed I won't include it so take all
the safe edges that exists between V and
anyone on the U side who's not currently
matched and just actually don't include
all the edges sorry
and then sample from all the edges with
this probability which says hey if that
edge was included with higher weight in
my optimal offline solution then sample
it with higher weight but down rate it
if that vertex type is appearing a lot
okay so if we want to interpret this if
there's an edge type that is included in
that opt solution that we did offline
and it's rarely going to arrive then
we're gonna sample it with really high
probability and if it's really really
common we'll sample it was slightly
lower probability and if the offline opt
didn't include it very much and it
arrives a lot then we're gonna basically
never sampling
the second algorithm that we're going to
use is based on the sort of contention
resolution techniques that have been
coming out in the last decade or so and
the rough idea here is going to be again
to take our offline optimal solution X
star which is fractional and sample some
binary vector Y from that in the offline
fix so fix some binary vector Y in the
offline phase and then use Y in the
online phase instead of this coin
flipping over the X star like we do in
the MMP algorithm so they're two super
super super simple algorithms first
question everyone always asks is hey
like what can we say about these
algorithms so we'll take this
competitive ratio definition and we'll
prove some stuff about those two
algorithms so the competitive ratio I'm
defining here is gonna be this sort of
worst-case result over all possible
instances of the problem of the expected
value of our algorithm that we've
designed where that expectation is taken
over both the internal randomness the
coin flips in the algorithm and the
arrival sequences and the expected value
of what an offline optimal are sorry an
optimal solution could have done right
and we have this LP orthodontist LP this
math program up upper bound so we we
have sort of a weak view on what X opt
can be and if we get closer to one
that's good to if we get closer to zero
that's bad
so that contention resolution based
algorithm when the arrival rates of the
vertices are our integral is going to
achieve in a competitive ratio where
we're dropping the 1 minus 1 over e from
that inability to solve to optimality a
multilinear extension of F we're
dropping this 1 minus 1 over e and then
this is the remaining worst case loss
that we'll get from the CR algorithm
and this MMP based one under constraints
on the offline side is going to achieve
a competitive ratio we're only losing
one minus one over e on top of that that
loss from the the multilinear extension
so in this setting where we have an
appropriately sized u with respect to
our time over which we're planning MMP
is gonna do a pretty good job yeah yeah
and we yeah right so we show that this
is I in the paper that sits tight with
respect to that that upper bound the
option that we play around with yeah
yeah so I'd like to put this up there
even though we have this constraint on
you because it's it's a bit nicer so we
have some early exploratory experiments
where we run on to Commons some modular
functions the first is budget additive
so here we're going to get points until
we run out of budget
so I match an edge I get the value of
that edge up until I hit a budget cap
and we can break this out over each of
the Issei off line vertices you if you
want to or clumps of the off line
vertices you to sort of start to mimic
things like advertising markets a bit
more and we'll also do some experiments
on a weighted coverage function the
framework here is going to be using an
extension to be matching some walao
actually the offline vertices to be
matched up to be times only an upper
bound and we'll very sort of the
constraints of the problem using this
number of times you can match to you
okay so one sort of is really
constrained all the way up to say an
infinite number of times matching to you
well you can do a pretty good job on
that one and our benchmark here is going
to be the offline true optimal so we're
gonna solve a big problem to optimality
we can do that because we have a lot of
patience and because people have been
spending time solving things optimality
so our early experiments will compare
against some sort of I don't say naive
baselines but the baselines you would
expect so one based on dependent
rounding one based on greedy so choosing
an available neighbor that maximizes a
marginal gain in that sub modular
function f every time B comes in and if
it doesn't exist will drop P and then
our two algorithms from earlier the the
multi linear extension one and the
contention resolution one MMP NCR and
some interesting early results pop out
of this so this is for not a super
constrained case this budget from one
which is very constrained all the way up
to 15 which is getting less constrained
so we're gonna be greedy really really
nicely here and sort of unsurprisingly
we're gonna beat the competitive ratios
that we prove for both those algorithms
pretty well as well right so here in
green and blue we have the two
algorithms that we present the
competitive ratios if you if you roll
the math out or you know oh because
we're solving two optimality they're
they're higher than you might think
we're doing a lot better there but one
thing that surprised us actually is when
we look at slightly more difficult
objectives like that weighted coverage
one greedy starts winning which is which
is interesting so maybe we need to do a
little bit more work on that but again
we're gonna have these nice theoretical
results wrapped around the two
algorithms that we proposed so the first
half of what I wanted to talk about just
to sort of get you in the mood of using
similarity to promote diversity in these
matching market
I know yeah yeah like DPP's for instance
are a good example of this maybe another
yeah
yes I like what you're what you're
talking about which would be I I'll try
and interpret that live so we have say
some set of types for vertices and we're
trying to equalize some set of like
sampling from each of the types of
vertices
that's right it might be harder I guess
you could bring the weights into that
constraint as well so maybe you want to
equalize the weighted sums of your
sampling yeah I think you're absolutely
right so every time I've talked to you
about this so that that comment comes up
it's sort of related to quota based sort
of right the DPP comment comes up so if
you talk to folks in industry yeah but
you know the people actually do
advertising a lot of them actually do
these determinantal point process based
approaches to doing diversity promotion
and those come with their own sort of
set of issues so one issue is that you
need a ton of data to be able to use
these accurately whereas in like a
hiring application you might not have a
ton of data I think that pretty much
sums up of the three different
approaches
you need to have like pretty good
yeah I think that's true yeah yeah I
think they're some yeah they're
certainly pros and cons to all of these
and one issue here is also like like you
said there is a lack of intuition and
that's some modular function like how do
we you're gonna see I use just a block
an arbitrary sum onto their function and
this one which is like a sum of some
square roots how do you decide on that
and we have some ongoing work actually
in two applications that are looking at
sort of active learning based ways of
asking the crowd what they think should
be a diverse but good set of elements so
in this context it's going to be a
diverse but good set and a what we're
calling a fantasy University where
you're trying to hire a bunch of
different faculty members and they have
a bunch of different types associated
with them and we're asking you know
basically what like what form of entropy
do you want to use yeah it's I don't
know if there's a good answer here there
are actually like like legal issues with
using quota based diversity promotion in
some areas so maybe that comment that
you made would not even be legal in some
areas it's unclear though
for that particular application
for Irene specifically it so objective
infection slipped in
I do see eye-to-eye on this like this is
not the I think the only way to do this
for sure for sure yeah so we have a long
term goal and that is to start looking
at diversity and fairness promotion in
hiring practices so matching workers to
firms or matching graduate students to
universities and I've just started with
my my student Candice Schumann working
on on this space in the context of
graduate admission so keep those some
modular thoughts in your mind or keep
quota based thoughts in your mind I
think both of them would work sort of in
an interesting way here let's walk now
into a hiring setting so say you're a
company and you want to hire a team of
workers or say you're a university and
you want to hire a cohort of graduate
students from some large pool of
applicants so what do you want well you
certainly want high individual worker
quality so you want good fit between a
workers skillset and the tasks that
you're going to ask that worker to do
but you might also want good interplay
between the workers so this has come up
for example at the University of
Maryland where we accept many PhD
students I mean we get a huge pool of
PhD students our acceptance rate is
actually pretty low but we end up
accepting I think well over 100 PhD
students per year to the computer
science department and and we don't want
to accept say 100 machine learning
theory students or something like that
because then all of our programming
languages faculty will leave and that's
not good constraints right there's an
interviewing budget or cost for us
there's there's an explicit budget at
the University of Maryland is is a
public university so we are we are often
budget constraints but there's also a
time budget right so when you get
thousands of applications you don't want
a human to actually sit down and spend
say four hours on every single
application we also have uncertainty
over individual quality
so for the sake of this talk let's
assume that we have two general ways to
gain information and I have a paper
coming out at interrupts in a couple
months that generalizes a lot of this
but for the sake of this talk let's
assume that we have two ways of
gathering information one is a resume
screening it's an automated resume
screening or in the case of the
University of Maryland we actually have
graduate students and faculty go into
sort of a homegrown application system
and rate students on various dimensions
so we have a cheap resume screen and we
have a slightly more expensive in-person
interview say a Skype interview that our
graduate admissions committee will do
now these resumes screens are extremely
cheap in terms of time or money but they
don't give you a ton of information
these in-person interviews are a bit
more expensive certainly in terms of
time and maybe they do give you more
information and you can imagine pushing
this out into fly outs into phone
screens into you know coding questions
things like that
our key question then is how should a
company or University allocate its
limited interviewing resources to select
the best wherever best came from could
be some modular could be not cohort of
new employees from a large set of that
job of job applicants right
specific to this talk how should that
company say allocate these cheap but
noisy resume screenings and these
expensive but in depth in person
interviews sequentially and such that we
come in under budget so our high-level
approach is going to be to model this as
a map problem a multi-armed bandit
problem and the combinatorial pure
exploration space so what that says is
that we're we're gonna think really hard
we're gonna do information gathering and
then at the end of the day we're gonna
pick some subset of these arms to call
our cohort so each applicants and this
talk is going to be represented by an
arm
we have uncertainty over the true value
of that individual arm we can learn
about those arms we can pull those arms
at some cost to gain information and our
goal is to find the optimal cohort
maximizing some objective by selectively
pulling arm and like I said that pure
exploration is going to be hey learn
learn learn and then pick the best set
in a one-shot deal
yeah this is just gonna be a
one-dimensional noise it's it's the
standard map setting there
I'll pull one arm and maybe I'll get
some value between zero and one yeah
great so we'll build on some nice recent
work that came from Chen at all I think
this started with a it was nips at the
time of Nerf's paper in 2014 we're gonna
select a subset of arms or that work
presents a method for selecting a subset
of arms with a certain combinatorial
structure for example a size upper bound
or a matching structure they give two
nice algorithms ones a fixed cost
confidence algorithm and ones a fixed
budget setting and we generalize both of
these two in the first paper into having
two ways of gathering information
instead of just one having these cheap
but bad and expensive but good methods
for sampling and like I said we have
work coming out in a couple months that
generalizes this much further so I'll
use the language weak poles the
equivalent to a resume screening of a
candidate where we're gonna get some
gain s which step to one at some cost J
which is set to one as well this is the
traditional map Pole but maybe we also
have some strong pole which is going to
give us more gain in information at some
greater cost Jane
so in this initial work we presented a
strong week armful algorithm which gave
us a nice acronym swap and the theory
side of this has proved just for linear
objectives not for some modular yet in
the experiments I'm gonna use a general
model sense a modular function but it's
gonna choose which arms to pull
sequentially and win-win de Polan based
on some Oracle and those Oracle's are
going to be in the experimental setting
a full optimal solve for a mono zone so
modular function the theory we have is
just for the linear case though
so let's walk look like it's a nice sort
of intuitive algorithm well first we're
going to initialize the empirical means
for every one of the arms so in the
applicant setting this is going to be
say running we actually do have some
basic like ml stuff which says things
like you know number of publications GRE
percentiles quartiles stuff like that
run those cheap but bad arm pulls at
least once exactly once on every arm and
then repeat the following steps until
we're competent enough ok so we're gonna
ask the Oracle for the best set of arms
given our current empirical means now we
have error bars around this right so we
can test now instead for the optimistic
best set of arms which is to say let's
assume that every empirical mean is at
the top of that error bar and the
pessimistic best set of arms which is to
say that that through our guests would
be the true mean would be the bottom of
those error bars okay so we have these
two sets if they're identical which sort
of you want to visualize that means that
we have some set of arms floating up
here such that even their sort of worst
pessimistic instantiations put them
above the best-case instantiations of
all the other arms so we have this like
separated group that really look good if
the best case in the worst case are the
same call it quits otherwise take the
symmetric difference between that
optimistic and pessimistic cohort and
think about that choose the most
uncertain arm that we have
and probabilistically weak or strong : I
think in this talk I don't go into sort
of where these apples are coming from
but we're gonna do a probabilistic
method so the generalization here is
that if alpha is equal to zero then then
this is just sort of a standard map
in the interest of time I'm just going
to breeze over these their theoretical
results so we have some pack pounds and
we have some some budget fixed budget
bounds here I don't think that these are
as important anymore because we have
this new oncoming work coming out but
our overview that theoretical results as
we extend this nice paper do de Chen at
all to the case of arm poles that cost
you some J that's say greater than one
but also give you some s in information
we give some nice results as well this
paper that uh explore different
probabilistic polling policies right so
if alpha zero then we just have week
bone Lee if we have alpha equals to 1
then we only have strong polls and
everything in between
and like I said these are only for the
linear case right now so that's that's
set
but I wanted to do in this talk now that
we're properly motivated is to discuss
sort of an ongoing experiment that we
have looking at a matching market that's
near and dear to all our hearts which is
to say right most of us I think I've
gone through this at least at some point
so our initial motivation here was
incorporating diversity into real-world
hiring processes and I'll do this
real-world experiment in the academic
real world which is in graduate
admissions so we're gonna use actual
emissions data from the University of
Maryland's department of computer
science to run some experiments here
we'll do some simulation experiments and
we also have some online ongoing a ghost
teen experiments all of this is IRB
approved because it sounds very scary to
use sort of ml to do hiring and I
totally agree with you on that all of
this is IRB approved we're not actually
making decisions based on this yet is
that that was Gary
and we're starting to work with a couple
of quantitative hiring firms in this
space as well just for data so formally
promoting diversity with with swap so
here's where this arbitrary some modular
function came out it's not that
arbitrary so this is a modular function
from the recommender systems literature
which says hey we have some set of K
types and
we're going to sum over each of the
types the square root of the value of
all the people I matched you in that
type so that square root is going to
enforce sort of diminishing marginal
return right so if I have exactly one
match of a specific type then I'll get
more sort of marginal gain from that one
match than I would if I had say four or
five matches of that individual type
so in our settings we're gonna look at
applicant attributes such as region or
gender area of interest
right so a I M l HTI and so on
our setup we trained a classifier on
past emissions data I think these
numbers should be updated we've been
doing this for quite a while now to
model decisions of the graduate
admissions committee okay again we are
not making actual missions decisions so
all the thoughts of bias that you're
thinking right now I'm thinking them as
well we have a numerical score in
negative one to positive sorry negative
2 to positive 2 in terms of quality this
comes from our homegrown system that we
run behind the scenes at Maryland where
reviewers are actually going in and
rating people both in terms of natural
language processing based sorry in terms
of national language but also in terms
of like a true numeric value we also
have an actual admissions decision so we
have did we choose to admit or did we
not choose to admit this student
we also do you know your standard data
mining stuff so you know we run off to a
character recognition on scans of
statements of purpose and on
recommendation letters and then we do
your you know do your first data science
approach to doing anything with text so
Lda and feature extraction we also look
through how do you use stuff in open
text for your decision this is all going
into a feature vector for the applicant
well what we want at the end of the day
is a yeah you want to say something
about whether the applicant is good or
not right I just don't understand how
you use the word cost you train it with
the previous data so excellent appears
in previous successful candidates okay
yeah yeah so you can do this there's
actually a lot of like there's a lot of
literature on on this this kind of thing
which is to try and interpret a
recommendation letters how good or how
bad they are so for example there's a
lot of business from likely psychology
literature and we implement this as well
which looks at trying to count things
like stand out and grindstone in ability
based words in in in the recommendation
letters and some of this is from quite a
while ago as well so like our initial
work I think was in the 90s and then up
to the early 2000s people really started
looking at this and so we just automate
that all right so the OCR is gonna say
you give me a PDF scan from some other
country we have to actually pick out the
text and then we can do some basic
feature extraction from the text and
then we do some some additional feature
extraction from like the literature that
looks at that recommendation letters we
also have sort of the obvious numeric
data associated with students as well so
the GPA is area and so on but the end
goal is that these are going to be
inputs into some sort of classifier or
actually a regression model which is
going to predict some sort of numeric
score for the student
the objective of our previous slide is
only part of the objective right you're
not only optimizing diversity all sorts
of quality yes so the quality
measurement is pushed into this you a
yeah so obviously if you goes up then
we're gonna get some additional gain
from that yep great
so using that classifier we ran some
simulations of swap diversifying for
different sets of attributes for example
in our application up until about two
years ago you only had two self-reported
binary gender so that's what we worked
on region of origin and then we compared
these results with past admissions
decisions right and past admissions
decisions are clearly not a proxy for
utilitarian matching so actually on a
couple of these papers is the professor
who was the Graduate Admissions Director
at the time so he gave us a lot of input
obviously he was doing some sort of
coverage based admissions as well
and we can obviously compared against a
simulated utilitarian matching based on
committee scores so what if people had
just accepted the top K based on the
committee scores the caveat here
obviously these are not policy
recommendations imagine I can imagine a
ton of negative and positive feedback
here so we are obviously learning from
past review scores which is going to be
biased as all heck the real score is
given without additional informations or
sorry our simulated sort of Skype
interviews are only going to give you a
particular type of information right so
if I do a resume screen versus a Skype
interview one of these isn't just worth
five times the resume screen I'm at so
I'm getting like additional information
that isn't even part of the resume
screen when I do a Skype interview right
and that might bias me as well when
comparing against reality like I said we
don't really know all the soft
operational constraints that went into
the actual admissions decisions we're
assuming you can measure the true
utility of a student and we are working
with a bunch of people outside of
computer science right now to try and
start alleviating some of these issues
so we have some grants and looking at D
biasing and we have a longitudinal study
that's just booting up at Maryland which
is going to track student success over
many many years so hopefully we can
start pushing back against this so in
terms of admissions experiment results
we do and actually end up with some some
pretty interesting and I would say
motivational results so basically if we
push for diversifying over a particular
types for example this self-reported
binary gender or region of origin we're
actually able to increase sort of the
coverage of these types at essentially
no cost to the utilitarian value that
pops out of the cohort that we accept
and I won't go in depth into like what
these numbers actually mean but
qualitatively that's true we can
rearrange cohorts that are accepted such
that we diversify substantially at this
basically no price of diversity right in
in practice
and some of the results that you would
expect to happen do in fact happen these
are actual admissions decisions from one
of the years at Maryland where there's a
huge bias toward North American students
and you can start diversifying over say
region of origin with almost no loss to
utilitarian quality
so about five mins left of the Raider
now it's only two minutes left I showed
you the fight it's okay so we have some
extensions we ran a live version of this
during the 2018 PhD hiring season again
just alongside of the admissions we're
not actually making decisions yeah I
guess I don't have too much time to go
into this via IRB approved language we
were able to talk to students actually
sort of after the admissions decisions
were out and run Skype interviews to see
sort of how much additional information
we might gain we can talk about this
offline so we have actual estimates for
these values s and J s being the amount
of information you gain and J being the
extra cost that a Skype interview cost
you in our case it was about six times
the amount of time to do a Skype
interview than to look up or somebody's
resume we did pick this fairly arbitrary
semaj allure function like I said my lab
is actually working quite a bit on sort
of human value judgment elicitation and
aggregation to try and learn a better
objective function that better reflects
sort of the ones in this case of a
committee of people who are looking to
admit students and one might ask hey how
are we partitioning people right like
I'm partitioning based on these
self-reported genders and region of
origin where did that come from
shouldn't this be fuzzy that's an open
question as well
and I'd like to just end on this sort of
nice extension that we have coming out
at nerves and then I'll take questions
so we've expanded this model
substantially
we just haven't run experiments on it
yet so basically we've expanded this
model to a tiered world where we're able
to sub select candidates over different
stages of the application process so say
your Google and you get 10 million
applicants and you do your resume screen
and then you have budget for ten
thousand phone screens and budget for
1004 one hundred job offers we have a
nice extension into this probe where you
tell us the number of stages that you
have in the budget that you have for
every stage and then we have an adaptive
algorithm that will tell you sort of who
and whom to allocate particular
interventions to and then how does sub
select down as you go from a million to
ten thousand to 100
so this extends the Swap model into both
the packet and the fixed budget settings
where we have general costs for arm
poles and general information games
forearm folds over multiple stages of
hiring and we ran some really basic
experiments really really basic
experiments on that graduate admissions
data and and we're able to basically a
blow out of the water the actual
admissions decisions that Marilyn made
in our to state process which is to do
resume screen and the Skype interview is
followed by an actual admissions offer
oh cool so I will leave it at that
question on the mighty unbranded to the
right approach for this problem the
modern bandits and pact approaches tend
to work well then you have lots and lots
of samples I imagine here you can get at
most like 10 unbiased reviews of how
good a student is so do you think like
there are other approaches which might
work well or you have a reason why you
think this is a good idea um so I agree
with this our baseline here is very
cheap very fast say ml based screening
the idea is that even one bump up here
so once you start doing say a phone
screen you're getting a ton more
information than a then I resume screen
and so brushing a lot of details under
the rug if that a ton more information
equates to something like a hundred
poles of an arm then you sort of get
around this issue a little bit so
basically by the time you're thinking
about people that actually flew out
you've had thousands of informations
worth of things like sort of cheap arm
pulls down here so the big question is
are you cutting off people too early on
based on just having one or two
different sort of cheap cheap estimates
of their signal my guess is the question
they didn't answer to that is still yes
so you would I don't know after bringing
some extra signal there right
good question of the partitioning and
there submodular function could you use
actually past date up and have some
objective in the past which would help
you automate that for example can I
measure collaborations or the OSE so
like a soft clustering that I've learned
and sometimes I think that's right I
don't know which measure to use actually
yeah I really don't know so so we cheat
a little bit in that there is like a
drop-down menu I'm sure this is the case
with most people's admissions where you
have like you know I'm interested in AI
first and comp bio second and Theory
third or whatever and so we're just
using that to start with I don't think
that's the right way to partition people
like most of us in this room for
instance would sit in multiple of those
divided like I have this issue right
like I I'm somewhere between theory nain
ml and I don't know how I would even
apply to myself so yeah I think you
should learn that in some way it's
unclear I guess these are graduate
omissions so a lot of these students
barely have sort of an academic
footprint so you might have to learn
that in some other way as well
so I had one question if you use
previous decisions to to teach the
algorithm right that's what you believe
then but you are also hinting and I'm
not sure over there and do this
correctly that you might also look at
the results of people that have been
screened both ways possibly but I was
wondering I mean the problem is always
you don't have the counterfactual right
so you the people who have been hired
and then you can see how the way they do
but it would be interesting to know what
even the in person screaming that's
totally right that's totally right
education and actually like even like
how very unwanted this in like the 90s
as well with an economics experiment
we're so Maryland is part of the Big Ten
which I'm now learning about another
sports person but I'm learning that this
means something beyond sports which is I
we're part of a research consortium so
we can actually pair with other
universities in the Big Ten to try and
start getting around some of this
counterfactual stuff but I mean at the
end of the day if somebody looks looks
bad to every single University and they
just disappear even though their true
value was good I don't know how to fight
that necessarily but we're starting to
so these are three big issues one is the
bias that we're going to encode right
like let's say that Jon prefers econ CS
candidates and he was the admissions
committee director for the last five
years then he comes kind of looking like
really good and we're gonna encode that
one that's that's bad too is this value
of students so like we need some sort of
like longitudinal study to say that a
student that we accepted ten years ago
ends up being amazing not just that like
their GRE scores are really good and
that makes you rate them well and then
three is exactly what you mentioned
which is this counterfactual analysis
and there's just gonna be a big sort of
data mining project there which is going
to be tracking people that we rejected
where they went right so did they go to
Google did they go to a sister
University or so on so what we want to
do is start off actually looking at the
faculty market as well because there you
can really track people a lot better
most people even if they don't say get a
faculty position don't disappear off the
face of the internet so we hopefully
will be able to track them as well
okay one can see a bit of what the swap
of whom this book I will make amends to
interview in the second stage it's not
necessarily the best people but every
and empirically I mean yeah so well swap
ends up doing and this actually follows
the intuition that we had which is you
know if you have this superstar 4.0 MIT
grad with five papers applying to your
university well it's still not clear
that you should accept them if say
you're Maryland so we're top ten but
we're not top one right in terms of a
lot of metrics and so there might be
some adverse selection that goes on but
whatever so this this person at the top
of the at the top of the list has such
little uncertainty around they're very
high empirical mean that we're not going
to Skype interview them what is sort of
swap algorithms start doing and so
ignore this for now ignore this sub
selection part what the swap algorithm
does is it hits these borderline
candidates that look like they're
empirical means are just below sort of
the top K but their error bars are huge
and so we're gonna say hey we should
think more about these candidates that
were really uncertain about and so what
what happens there is and there's a nice
paper I didn't get to it here we have
some extra work coming out soon that
also looks at a fairness in banded
algorithms so there's some nice work
that came out of like Michael Kern's and
Aaron Ross group in 2016 that looks at
fairness individual fairness and in
multi armed bandits and they basically
make the the this this this claim that
yeah you should never accept people who
are fundamentally you know worse than
the people that you're accepting up here
but when you have these error bars
floating around that say hey you know I
think you I think my best guess my
empirical mean for you is lower than
most people that I'm looking at right
now but your error bars are really big
because I have very few say training
points right so these are the types of
people that don't tend to apply to
graduate school very often then you
should think really hard about these
folks before rejecting or accepting them
and that's what swaps doing as well so
it's the folks who are sort of
borderline and borderline just under but
have huge hair bars
usually the best candidates interview
this way no not for Skype interviews no
not breath I don't know if you're coming
from CS or econ lacy so in computer
science at least the two universities
I've been at offers are given before
even fly outs so in a lot of disciplines
like psychology for instance you
actually do a fly out and interview
somebody and then give them an offer and
see us it's like you know if that case
of the MIT 4.0 with five publications we
will put very little effort into
accepting that person you just look at
that and you're like alright I'm gonna
accept this person so we I doubt with
what Skype interview I mean we might
spec interview to try to sell the person
on coming to Maryland for example but
yeah okay I think we should take a break
and thank you again
[Applause]